on va parler des punaises de lit euh
punaises de lit c'est le nouveau
cauchemar des Français et on va vous
donner tous les conseils pour que vous
en débarrasser c'est un truc de fou en
ce moment tout le monde en parle c'est
vraiment même de jolis une cause que
l'État a pris très au sérieux les
punaises de lit je vous lis c'est un
truc de malade Gilles merdes peut se
retrouver également dans votre lit voilà
on aura un
roman en faune invasive qui sera avec
nous dans un instant pour répondre à
toutes nos questions lui c'est un pont
hein je peux vous dire lui les punaises
elle voit arriver le gars déjà qu'est-ce
que tu fais bah je suis en train de
faire mes valises il arrive dans une
heure voilà Batman
et là lui voilà c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est un véritable fléau qui semble
prendre de plus en plus d'ampleur voici
les pires voisins d'un foyer français
sur 10 les punaises de lit selon une
récente étude 11% des Français auraient
été infectés par des punaises de lit
entre 2017 et 2022 ça m'a tellement
angoissé que j'en ai pleuré ses petits
insectes de quelques millimètres qui
nous piquent et se nourrissent de notre
sang pendant notre sommeil ruine la vie
de certains qui peine parfois à s'en
débarrasser et qui doivent faire appel à
des spécialistes je fais exprès en fait
de bien bien noyer le matelas je veux
vraiment que c'est ici de pénètre bien
alors comment faire pour les éradiquer
efficacement punaises de lit le nouveau
cauchemar des Français tous les conseils
pour enfin s'en débarrasser ce soir dans
TPMP ça me rappelle tellement de
souvenirs ce truc alors merci Romain la
soeur ça m'est arrivé c'est pour ça je
te vois toi tu as eu des punaises dans
le slip
vas-yves est avec nous expert
international je vous le dis vous êtes
très calé en rail en moustique aussi
ouais toutes ces bestioles là toutes ces
bestioles dès que vous voyez une
bestiole fitness moi faire de toute
façon mon vieux hein d'accord ouais
j'arrive là personne s'en va donc quand
on bosse sur les punaises elles sont en
direct donc c'est plus facile comment
vous êtes arrivés dans le dans le milieu
de
mes études
de formation en fait donc j'ai un
doctorat et je travaille spécifiquement
sur ces sur la manière dont ces espèces
là en fait elle connaît colonisent nos
environnements alors en ce moment on a
l'impression et vous aussi chez vous je
suis sûr que c'est là vous avez
l'impression que moi on a l'impression
que tout le monde parle que de punaises
de lit il y en a partout on a vu une
histoire là qui s'est passé dernièrement
aussi dans les dans un lieu public c'est
vrai que là en ce moment la punaise et
partout j'étais à deux doigt de recruter
une punaise en chroniqueuse
alors c'est quoi déjà une punaise
alors c'est un insecte comme beaucoup
d'espèces Invalides comme le moustique
et c'est un insecte qu'on connaissait
plus parce que
ça fait 6 mm l'adulte à 7 mm mais la
majeure partie du temps tu la vois pas
parce qu'elle est elle est souple
sommier sous le matelas et bien planqué
pendant la journée parce que
principalement elle a besoin de faire
des repas de sang donc tous les sexes
piquent tous les stades pour se
développer elle a besoin de boire du
sang que vous êtes tous à la même
enseigne il y a pas de catégorie sociale
de piquer pour pour effectivement
grandir et donc en fait elle va se
planquer dans les endroits pas très loin
de vous 30 40 cm maximum et puis quand
vous êtes tranquille je dis j'ai
tendance à dire la chambre à coucher
mais il y a les toilettes aussi il y en
a qui restent un petit peu longtemps aux
toilette le canapé le siège de cinéma le
siège de bus et les commissariats elles
ont des elles ont des talkie-walkie
ouais ça y est il est en train de dormir
en fait elle génère du CO2 et des odeurs
humaines en fait qu'on appelle les
keromes des phéromones humaines elles te
repèrent à ça elle est pas très loin
elle monte et elle arrive quand tu es
peinard la nuit entre deux trois heures
du mat tu bouges pas elle te pique elle
fait son pas de sang qui dure entre 10
et 20 minutes et puis elle redescend et
là pendant 15 jours avec digérer la
rentrée dessert
alors si elle fait son pas de son
intégrale elle va se mettre à digérer
ensuite pendant 10-15 jours pour ensuite
pondre si c'est une femelle et puis
grandir si c'est si c'est un animal qui
est en train de grandir donc 200
rapports par jour ah non là la
reproduction en général la femelle c'est
une fois dans sa vie je suis déçu fin tu
vois je travaille sur un truc qui est
pas très fascinant
et en fait un rapport traumatique dans
sa vie elle a assez ensuite de sperme
pour en se lancer ses œufs et puis
pondre 15 à 20 œufs par jour par exemple
500 dans sa vie pourquoi on a
l'impression qu'il y en a de plus en
plus hein bah parce qu'il y en a de plus
en plus un million de français tous les
ans 1,6 c'est combien
la question est con non c'est pas con
non non carrément pas c'est un million
d'interventions des professionnels il y
a des études qui ont été faites par
notre chambre syndicale qui s'appelle la
cs3d en France on a beaucoup d'échangé
avec les ministères pour essayer de
faire bouger les lignes et ça fait quoi
en fait une pièce de vie est-ce que
c'est dangereux non alors ça transmet
pas de maladie déjà c'est pas le
moustique c'est pas tout ça ça transmet
pas de maladie on a fait quoi sur la
peau alors ça fait des petits rougeurs
ça fait des ce qu'on appelle les œdèmes
de surface et voilà et donc qui
apparaissent plus moi rapidement
je vais dormir un jour dans un hôtel et
je vais dormir je vous jure je dors avec
un pote qui s'appelle Jérôme
il doit me regarder on dort dans le même
en fait on dort dans le même lit c'est
un lit deux places
on se réveille le matin on était un
tournoi de poker d'ailleurs Deauville et
on se réveille le matin il est piqué de
partout par des punaises et moi j'ai
rien eu comment ça c'est en fait chez le
moustique c'est bien connu ça pique en
fonction des Rhésus sanguins et punaise
on n'est pas encore à ce stade là on
fait énormément de recherche parce que
moi je fais encore bouffer lui ils ont
pas le temps sur moi quoi en fonction de
ses odeurs sont dégagement de CO2 sa
température à la suite qui est probable
alors on veut pas savoir ce qui s'est
passé la nuit
mais potentiellement en fait ouais tu as
des pots qui plaisent à la punaise
d'autres qui plaisent beaucoup moins et
donc c'est vrai et c'est exacerbé chez
le moustique chez le moustique on voit
que ça pique certaines pots et pas
d'autres alors comment faire pour ne pas
avoir punaise que c'est ça la question
qu'on se pose tous parce que là on a
l'impression qu'il y en a partout dans
les toilettes sur le canapé dans le lit
est-ce que la chaleur impacte sur la
proliférations parce que contrairement à
nous qui aurait régulons notre
température les insectes ils savent pas
réguler tout seul leur température donc
ils sont victimes de la température
extérieure et en fait les cycles
s'accélèrent le métabolisme s'accélère
avec la température donc plus il fait
chaud plus le métabolisme s'accélère
plus elle digère le sang rapidement et
plus elle est capable de rapidement
c'est ça alors quand il fait froid elles
ont est-ce que elles se mettent ce qu'on
appelle en diapose tu as l'impression
qu'il y a dans disparu elle pique plus
elle sent encore là mais elle s'en
métabolisme ralentie et dès qu'il va
faire donc
si tu l'as ouais long encore
sans se nourrir en plus ça reste un an
ouais on dit à peu près un an sans fin
donc vous traitez jamais l'impression
d'avoir été Ramadan parce que vous avez
pas fait appel à nous et puis bah
finalement six mois après ça repique
quoi alors comment on fait pour se
débarrasser de ces punaises bon déjà il
faut savoir un truc c'est que c'est pas
un problème d'hygiène quoi contrairement
au bled contrairement au rap ça nouvelle
pour Gilles
c'est pas un problème je dirais
d'insalubrité on retrouve des punaises
dans tous les grands hôtels et dans tous
les petits hôtels
50% des gens se contaminent quand ils
font des des séjours à l'extérieur de
chez eux
50%. donc et beaucoup à l'étranger donc
beaucoup de randonneurs
quand on ramène sa valise d'un pays
où il y a des punaises il faut la mettre
non il faut la mettre dans sa baignoire
et ouvrir la balle je vais vous donner
quelques conseils alors écoutez chez
vous c'est important c'est de bien avoir
en tête que il y a déjà 50% des gens qui
ne parlent pas de leurs problèmes de
punaise à leurs amis c'est-à-dire qu'on
a l'impression de honte ce qui n'est pas
le cas puisque ça touche tout le monde
alors les chéris si vous nous regardez
par les angles vraiment on ne vous
jugera jamais je vous le dis franchement
dites-le juste avant avant que nous
disiez vous donner deux trois deux trois
choses pour éviter d'avoir les fenêtres
comment on sait qu'on en a en fait tu
sais que tu en as malheureusement quand
ça pique d'accord et en fait moi
j'invite les gens et on bosse beaucoup à
essayer d'informer le grand public sur
c'est quoi une déjection de punaises
c'est quoi une punaise et c'est quels
sont les premiers signes qu'il faut
réussir à repérer pour voir une punaise
une punaise c'est pas simple parce que
ça se planque et elle va venir te voir
quand tu es tranquille et
potentiellement quand tu t'aperçois pas
le chien qui sursaute là alors il y a
des détecteurs
en France avec des professionnels qui
détecte les punaises et qui sont eux
capables de détecter une punaise enfin
le chien détecte nous on en est pas
capable à part visuellement par contre
moi ce que je conseille toujours c'est
que si vous avez des doutes et tu as
complètement raison tu reviens de voyage
aspirer soigneusement votre logement et
regarder dans le sac aspirateur si vous
aspirez votre logement avec une
suspicion de punaise rangez pas
l'aspirateur dans le placard sinon on va
ressortir alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour éviter les punaises éviter
les punaises si vous avez un doute
ensuite vous congelez vos vêtements
manger les vêtements
ouais on a on a des steaks et de
t-shirts
combien de temps alors c'est 12 - 20
degrés attention nos congels usuels
montent à moins 18 c'est vraiment pour
un 20 degrés et puis 72 heures la vapeur
mais il faut monter au-delà de 56 57
degrés d'accord on va faire humide alors
tu imagines qu'on va faire sèche il faut
monter en plus
il y a du matériel amateur et du
matériel professionnel
c'est important donc les conseils c'est
ça c'est c'est la moindre suspicion
aspirez bien votre votre logement rangez
bien le logement si vous avez suspicion
vous revenez de voyage votre valise
intégrale vous la mettez au congel alors
le matériel informatique ou métallique
dont j'aime mais il y a des il y a des
spray de cryogénie
et donc voilà ça c'est les premiers
signes et si vous si vous voyez
plusieurs insectes malheureusement c'est
difficile à enrayer il faut rapidement
vous tourner vers des professionnels qui
eux pour mettre en place un traitement
efficace d'accord qui va passer la
plupart des cas parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un peu arrow sur la chimie dans
notre société c'est ça sur
malheureusement aujourd'hui vu la
bestiole à laquelle on a affaire face
c'est pas arrivé mon chimie les remèdes
de grand-mère et les huiles essentielles
pulvérisées parce qu'on revient sur
nature et découverte elles ont compris
fonctionne pas
action à Paris par exemple ouais alors
on pourrait en tout cas nous on milite
vraiment pour des choses coordonnées au
niveau mais la problématique c'est que
c'est une problématique privée c'est un
des punaises chez toi tu sais pas si on
envoie tu vas à l'hôtel tu sais pas si
la chambre de la couture c'est des in
donc les punaises soient pour qu'elle
soit toute égo est-ce que c'est ça un
rail des trains à la set de l'assaut ok
le est-ce que pour avoir l'uniforme
aussi je me la facture je me la facture
merci
donc c'est vraiment c'est le froid ou la
chaleur on a compris voilà la chaleur et
puis les professionnels qui eux vont
intervenir avec des produits un peu plus
costaud quand vous sentez que
l'infestation vous échappe en vous
pensez que vous en avez ramené de chez
des amis et autres il faut communiquer
c'est pas ça c'est pas un problème
d'hygiène vous devez pas avoir honte
d'avoir des punaises de lit chez vous
potentiellement toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles sont frappés de
la même manière et c'est surtout les
jeunes moins de 30 ans pourquoi parce
que étudiant parce que qui partent de la
maison qui vont vivre à l'extérieur dans
une île qui sortent voilà échange qui
vont chez les potes sur Daniel
45 ans que la punaise elle va pas la
flotte elle va pas la ramener chez
Boulanger en fait voilà c'est ça c'est
vraiment pas un problème d'hygiène et si
vous sentez que la situation vous
échappe il y a des professionnels qui
savent bien bosser en France on les
forme aujourd'hui on les sensibilise
nous par ailleurs on essaie de bien
sensibiliser c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis là j'ai l'impression
même attendez parce que j'ai
l'impression que même l'État prend ça
très au sérieux les punaises de lit
impactent tellement la vie des Français
que les tâches choisies de prendre ce
sujet à bras le corps il y a un numéro
de téléphone qui a même été mis en place
c'est un truc de fou 7 % des Français
qui ont été concernés ces cinq dernières
années qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit au
téléphone
merci c'est tout pour moi et Romain
merci en tout cas est-ce que tu pourras
venir nous parler des rats elle est
grand plaisir franchement parce que là
c'est encore plus grave il y a un
nouveau truc avec les rats j'aimerais
que tu reviennes demain sur les rages un
nouveau truc et faites très très
attention on nous dira ça demain tu
répondras à ma question very demain un
truc de fou sur les rats un nouveau truc
là ça me fait très très peur cette
histoire merci vraiment d'avoir été avec
nous vous connaissez Barbie
est-ce que vous avez envie de le
ressembler écoute moi je préfère les
punaises quand même très bien parce
qu'on va parler de Barbie Botox alors ça
vous avez vu que le film Barbie a
cartonné il a battu tous les records et
ça devient viral toutes les jeunes
filles veulent ressembler très pour très
à Barbie donc c'est des opérations de
chirurgie esthétiques vous allez voir on
va chez le chirurgien et on lui dit je
veux être comme Barbie moi à l'époque je
me rappelle j'avais été voir le Surin je
lui ai dit je veux être comme Enrico
Macias voilà
Eden qui sera avec nous qui a commencé
tu as transformation en bas oui vous
allez lui dire ce que vous en pensez
bien entendu
elle est très jolie c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit je l'ai pas encore vu mais c'est ce
qu'on dit les équipes et on aura signé
au voilà chirurgien qu'on connaît bien
qui Louis VII qui lui souhaite avertir
face à cette pratique ce sera dans un
instant merci et demain on se retrouve
avec les